what were you frustrated about at the
end of the uh second quarter when you
got that
tactical uh I know I saw you when you
said about the fan you know that was not
a true all that was not the only thing
he said um but I knew you would be the
first one to to point out something like
that I'm not going to say what he said
but I knew you were going to be the
first one to put out something like that
so I just saw him man it's just funny he
always seem to be the first one to put
some bad stuff about me first of all 99%
of the stuff I've written about you been
good I I don't know I was sitting two
rows behind
us all right so it was the only thing he
was that time he said something the only
thing that was what you reacted to yeah
I was hearing the whole first half right
or you didn't hear anything he was
definitely holler okay there we go you
put out something that was just the only
thing but was the final St the final was
the thing that it's not the issue I'm
just seeing you seems to be the first
one to always put something bad about me
that's fine it's all over why did you
ask for the fan to be ejected because he
was cursing me the whole first half too
why didn't you ask for be ejected in the
first half then because I never would e
ja a fan they pay for tickets but I had
enough you know it's a little bit of
frustration you turned your head and
looked over at him after he said that
that's I mean that's what we saw yeah
that's
fine be the the better guy in the media
right it's all right like you fairly
portrayed in the media
no